[موسيقى]
النهارده عاوزه احكي لكم عن حرب ضخمه
وخطيره في العالم بقى لها كم سنه وبدات
تشتعل اكتر مؤخرا ومعروفه اعلاميا خارج
النطاق العربي والافريقي كويس لكن نادرا
ما حد واخد باله منها عندنا للاسف حرب
بتحدد جزء من مستقبل التكنولوجيا وتطور كل
جهاز حديث ممكن تفكر فيه من اول بعض اهم
الاسلحه واجهزه رصدا الفضاء لحد موبايلك
او لاب توبك اللي انت بتشوفني منه دلوقتي
وغيره وغيره بس علشان افهمكم حدود الحرب
دي خلوني اوريكم خريطه مهمه جدا الاول دي
خريطه لجمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه ثاني
اكبر دوله من حيث المساحه في افريقيا بعد
الجزائر ورقم 11 عالميه دوله غنيه جدا
بموارد طبيعيه فوق الخيال وجهه الشرق
تحديدا في البلد دي بيعوم على كنز رهيب من
المعادن الحيويه لا ادق واخطر الصناعات
المكان الطبيعي المفترض لدوله الكونغو
بسبب مواردها دي انها تكون في مقدمه الدول
لكن العكس هو اللي حاصل الكونغو بقى لها
عشرات الس في نزاعات وصراعات وفساد واسع
زي ما انتم شايفين كده النقط اللي قدامكم
دي هي مناجم شرق الكانغو مناجم ماس
ويورانيوم وقصدير ونحاس وحديد وتنتالوم
اللي بيستخدم في صناعه الطيارات وغيره كل
حاجه تقريبا لكن اللي هنركز عليه في حلقه
النهارده هو مجموعه النقط اللي تحت دي
الكوبالت او الذهب الازرق معدن كان لحد
وقت قريب ما لوش اي اهميه قبل ما يتحول
حاليا لواحد من اهم معادن العالم الكونغو
يا اخوانا فيها نص كميه الكوبلت المعروفه
والموجوده في الكوكب حاليا وبتنتج حوالي
70% من الانتاج العالمي الكوبلت بيدخل في
صناعات بطاريات كل الاجهزه الحديثه تقريبا
لكن وجوده بدا يتحول لوجود مؤثر جدا مع
تحول العالم دلوقتي بخطوات متسارعه للطاقه
النظيفه لدرجه انه في اواخر سنه 2021
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه بعتت عدد
من مراسلينها لثلاث قارات وعملوا اكتر من
100 مقابله وفحصوا الاف الوثائق علشان
يتتبعوا الصراع المعقد حوالين الكوبلت
عالميه ومن سبع سنين تقريبا ولحد اللحظه
والصين بيتعلم على امريكا في الحرب دي
وبتحقق نصر ورا التاني الصينيين حاليا
شركات وحكومه بيتحكموا في 70% من قطاع
التعدين الكونغولي كله وفي خ حصل صفقات
استحواذ ودعاوى فساد وسرعات على الحكم
وليله كبيره الكلام ده يخلينا نسال شويه
اسئله مهمه جدا زي مثلا ايه هو الكوبلت ده
وعرفناك بشر من امتى بالظبط وهل كان
بالاهميه دي من ساعه ما عرفناه ولا اهميته
دي ظهرت لما حصلت الطفره التكنولوجيه
مؤخرا ومين اكبر منتجين الكوبالت عالميا
وبيستخدم في ايه بالظبط وليه في صراع خفي
حوالين التحكم في اماكن تعدين الكوبالت
عالميا ومين اللي منتصر في الحرب دي لحد
النهارده امريكا ولا الصين ده عينه من
الاسئله المهمه والمثيره اللي هندردش
حواليها في حلقه النهارده بس قبل ما نبدا
بفكركم بالاشتراك في القناه لان اشتراككم
مهم جدا لتطوير القناه واستمرارنا في
تقديم محتوى المخبر الاقتصادي بفكركم برضو
ان كل حلقاتنا اللي فاتت مترجمه للغه
الانجليزيه فما تنسوش تشاركوها مع اصحابكم
الاجانب وتعرفوهم علينا انا اشرف ابراهيم
المختصادي
[موسيقى]
حابب اشكر شركه على رعايتها الحلقه دي زي
شركه وساطه ماليه عالميه انا شخصيا بتداول
معها لانها مرخصه من اقوى الهيئات
العالميه زي هيئه الخدمات الماليه في سيشل
اف اس اي وبقدر اسحب فلوس بسهوله من غير
اي قيود وبقدر انفذ التداول بشكل سريع
وكمان بيدوني 100% بونص على الايداع ولو
انت لسه مبتدئ في التداول تقدر تجرب معهم
من خلال برنامج
اللي بيساعدك تنسخ تداولات المستثمرين
المحترفين ولو كنت محترف فتقدر تقدم
تداولاتك للنسخ كمتداول محترف وتحصل على
بونص ميه في الميه لو فتحت حساب في ثواني
من اللينك الموجود تحت الفيديو وهتلاقوه
برضو في التعليقات فيسبوك قبل ما اوريكم
الوضع الحالي للصراع على الكوبلت لازم
اديكم خلفيه سريعه عنه هو واحد من اقدم
الفلزات المعروفه ويكاد يكون الاقدم وان
كانت الحضارات القديمه عرفته كماده ملونه
مخلوطه بفلز البيزموت الا هو شبه الرصاص
والاصدير هو معدن عالمي من قديم الازل حتى
قبل ما يكت بشكل واضح يعني زمان كان
بيستخدم علشان يدي لون ازرق غني للمنحوتات
الزجاجيه وتم اكتشافه في بعض المنحوتات
المصريه القديمه وبرضو لقيناه في بعض
المجوهرات الفارسيه اللي تاريخها بيرجع
للالفيه الثالثه قبل الميلاد وبرضو كان
موجود في ادوات ومنحوتات بانقاض بعض المدن
الرومانيه القديمه وصولا لبعض الاثار
الصينيه اللي يرجع تاريخها لاكتر من عشر
قرون هننط نطه واسعه وهنوصل لسنه 1735 لما
الكيمياء السويدي جورج براند اكتشفوا
واطلق عليه اسم شبه معدني وايوه ما لقاش
اسماء غير الاسم المبتكر ده طبعا قبل ما
عمال المناجم الالمانيا ينقذونا ويسموه
وده لفظ من الاساطير الالمانيه لنوع من
العفاريت بيسكن في المناجم وتحت الارض
عمال الملاجم افتكروا ان الكوبلت من اثار
العفاريت دي بسبب لونه الازرق فوصلنا
للتسميه الحاليه له هنعدي حوالي 200 سنه
وهنوصل لاكتشاف النظير المشع للكوبلت اللي
هو كوبل 60 سنه 1938 واللي بيدخل في عمليه
توليد
سنه لما بدات طفره الاجهزه الالكترونيه
الحديثه وبدانا نشوف الهواتف الذكيه
والحواسيب المحموله والالواح الرقميه وحتى
العاب الاطفال المتطوره واي شيء تقريبا في
بطاريه ليثيوم اللي الكوبلت يعتبر جزء
اساسي في تصنيعها لكن النقل الاوسع كانت
مع بدء تصاعد ممكن السيارات الكهربائيه في
العشر سنين الاخيره وهي الموجه اللي ساهمت
في تصاعد التنافس على استخراج الكوبلت
والسيطره على اماكن وجوده وعمليه معالجته
ولما نحط جنب ده ان اكبر سوق للسيارات
الكهربائيه في العالم هو الصين اللي
بتستحوز على قرابه 60% من مبيعات المركبات
الكهربائيه عالميه اكبر مكون بيستهلك
الكوبالت حاليا هو تصنيع بطاريات المركبات
الكهربائيه يعني كل عربيه تسلا فيها
بطاريه ساعتها متوسطه الكبيره بيدخل في
تصنيعها كميه كوبلت توصل لخمسه كيلو كوبلت
تقريبا وقبل ما حد فيكم يستهون بالكميه
فاحنا بنتكلم هنا عن كميه كوبالت لبطاريه
عربيه واحده ودي كميه اكبر ب الضعف من
كميه الكوبلت اللي بتحتاجها بطاريه موبايل
او لاب توب وعلى سيره شركه تسلا عملاقه
السيارات الكهربائيه الامريكي هنا هتبدا
تظهر ملامح حرب الكوبالت اللي بيحصل
بالظبط بقى وركزوا معي كويس جدا زي ما قلت
لكم في اول الحلقه ان 70% من انتاج
الكوبلت العالمي بيجي من الكونغو والمناجم
هناك مركزه في جنوب البلد المضطرب بشكل
شبه دائم والاهالي هناك افقر من الفقر
وبيعيشه على اقل من اتنين دولار يوميا في
الكونغو هنلاقي نوعين من المناجم المناجم
القانونيه ودي اللي بتملك حقوق التنقيب
فيها شركات اجنبيه واخده تراخيص من
الحكومه ومعاها الامكانيات والادوات
والمناجم غير القانونيه واللي بتسمى مناجم
حره ودي بينقب فيها اهالي المناطق والقرى
المحيطه بالمناجم تنقيب نص قانوني كده
وبرضه الشركات بتشتري اللي بيلاقوه باسعار
بخسه جدا عن طريق وسطاء محليات المناجم
القانونيه بتنتج 70% من انتاج البلد من
الكوبلت والمناجم غير القانونيه بتنتج الت
في الميه الباقيين الحقيقه ان استغلال
الدول اللي عندها موارد طبيعيه زي الكونغو
كده وحلبها ومص دمها من قبل الدول الكبرى
مش قصه جديده يكفي بس تشوف تاريخ فرنسا
هناك واللي عملته ولسه بتعمله لحد دلوقتي
وامتصاصها الخيرات بعض اهم دول غرب
افريقيا ولا تاريخ امريكا نفسها اللي شفطت
اليورانيوم من الكونغو برده واستخدمته في
صناعه قنبلهاي هيروشيما ونجازاكي وموجود
في جزء من ترسيناتها نوويه الحاليه لكن لو
ركزنا على الكونغو تحديدا دلوقتي فالجديد
بقى ان دوله تانيه خالص من الشرق فضلت
تزحف وتعمل في صمت لحد ما تفوقت على القوه
الاستعماريه الغربيه التقليديه وبقت هي
اللي بتحلب القمح الدوله دي هي الصين
لدرجه انه تم تسميه الكونغو بالكونغو
الصينيه بسبب النفوس الصيني الكبير في
البلد خاصه في قطاع التعديه النفوس ده بدا
سنه 2017 تقريبا لما الحكومه الكونغوليه
تعاقدت مع مجموعه من الشركات الصينيه
الممنوكه للدوله لتاسيس مشروع مشترك باسم
كومين لتعدين الكوبلت والنحاس وقتها ده
كان اهم مشروع صيني في افريقيا لدرجه انه
تسمى ساعتها بصفقه القرن وفي سنه 2016
شركه
بعد 80% من حقوق ملكيه منجم تنكي وده احد
اكبر مناجم النحاس والكوبلت في الكونغو
والعالم مقابل 2.6 مليار دولار بعيته شركه
التعدين الصينيه العملاقه مجموعه صيام
اوسي شهيره والمملوكه الجزئيه للدوله وهي
بالمناسبه تاني اكبر منتج للكوبلت في
العالم حاليا لكن خطه هيمنه مجموعه سيام
اوسيس الصينيه ما وقفتش على كده وامتدت
لمكان اهم واخطر المنطقه اللي قدامكم دي
هي منطقه كسانفو جنوب شرق الكانغو منطقه
فيها واحد من اكبر احتياطيات العالم غير
المستغله من النحاس والكوبلت حوالي 3.1
مليون طن متر من الكوبلت وضعفهم من النحاس
في سنه 2020 مجموعه سام او سي كملت
الاستحواذ على كسانفو من خلال شركتها
التابعه لها
اللي اشترت 95% من مقابل 550 مليون دولار
ورغم ان الشركه دخلت في نزاع قانوني مع
الحكومه الكونغوليه في 2022 بعد ما
اتهمتها الحكومه بعدم سداد مستحقاتها من
عوائق تعدين الكوبلت وحكمت محكمه كونغوليه
لصالح الحكومه رغم دوا على ارض الواقع
المنجم ما زال في قبضه الشركه بل وبدات
تضخ في استثمارات بعشرات الملايين من
الدولارات ضمن خطه لرفع انتاج المانجم
تتضمن ضخ الصين لواحد فاصل 8 مليار دولار
في مرحلتها الاولى بس مين بقى اللي شايف
كل التحركات دي وعمال يعض على صوابعه
الولايات المتحده مشكله امريكا هنا مش بس
هيمنه الصين على التحكم في انتاج اكبر
دوله فيها كوبالت على وش الارض وهي كونغو
وانما مشكلتها كمان ان الصين بتعالج
بنفسها 80% من الكوبلت في العالم حاليا
تمهيدا لاستخدامه في الصناعات المختلفه
علشان تكونوا معايا في الصوره يا اخواننا
لازم تعرفوا انه على عكس النفط مثلا مش
دايما الدول اللي المعاده الموجوده في
اراضيها بتكون المستفيده الاكبر واحد
اسباب ده مش بس حلب الدول دي من قبل دول
تانيه وانما لان دوره انتاج المعادن
وسلاسل توريد المرتبطه بها معقده اكتر
بكتير من دوله النفط دوره الانتاج دي بتمر
باربع مراحل رئيسيه المرحله الاولى هي
التنقيب الاستخراج والمرحله التانيه هي
مرحله المعالجه وبتتضمن تنقيه المعادن دي
من الشوائب علشان تبقى اكثر نقاء مجهزه
للتصنيع اما المرحله الثالثه هي مرحله
انتاج المكونات حسب استخدام المعدن
المرحله الرابعه بقى والاخيره هي صناعه
الشيء اللي هيدخل فيه المعدن كل مرحله من
المراحل دي لها صعوباتها وتعقيداتها
وبتتطلب تقنيات متطوره غالبا ما بتكونش
متوفره للدول المنتجه اللي اغلبها بيقف
عند المرحله الاولى او الثانيه ولا الصين
بقى بتتحكم في 80% من العمليه دي كاستخراج
ومعالجه وانتاج علشان كده هنلاقي حد زي
مارتن مدير معهد امن سلاسل التوليد القومي
اتابع لاهم مش بحث امريكا لاند بيقول ان
الصين فهمت بشكل افضل من الولايات المتحده
الحاجه الملحه للوصول للمواد الاستراتيجيه
وانها مكتفتش بانها تلاقي المواد دي بس
وانما نجحت في تخزينها وده شيء فشلت فيه
الولايات المتحده مؤخرا وعلشان كده برضو
كان واضح جدا وهو بيقول ان قدره الصين
الحاليه على منع اي دوله تانيه من الوصول
للكوبلت تحديدا بتخلق ضعف واضح في جدار
الامن القومي الامريكي لانه في الوقت اللي
الصين بتكدس فيه الموارد النادره والحرجه
زي الكوبلت وبتتحكم في سلاسل توريد بتاعته
من الاول للاخر هنلاقي ان امريكا عندها
حاجه اسمها مخزون الامن القومي من المواد
الحرجه وده مخزون من المواد النادره
كمعادن المصادر طاقه وخلافه بتخلي امريكا
عندها المواد دي دايما وبتجدد المخزون ده
علشان يكون بمثابه درع ليها اوقات الازمات
والحروب علشان مفيش دوله يكون لها اليد
العليا عليها المخزون ده الولايات المتحده
استهلكته على مدار العقود السابقه كان في
سنه 1989
مليار دولار حاليا المخزون ده شحن لدرجه
انه اللي فيه بيساوي 888 مليون دولار
باستا دلوقتي لكن خلينا نقول ان الثغره
اللي عماله ده بيقول عليها مش خطيره على
الاقل في الوقت الحالي لكذا صعبه منها ان
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه لبنتاجون بتفرض
بند قانوني اسمه بند المعادن الخاصه على
مقاوله دفاع ومورديهم انهم يجيبوا سبائك
الكوبالت ومنتجات الصلب من جوه امريكا او
من حليف للبلد وده اللي اكده قانون تفويض
الدفاع الوطني الامريكي لسنه 2023 اللي
طالب فيه البنتاجون بتعزيز مخزونه من
المعادن الهامه والحفاظ على شراء المعادن
من بره الصيف والسبب التاني ان الصين
حريصه على استمرار ارادتها من مبيعات
الكوبلت وهي ايرادات بمليارات الدولارات
وبالتالي مش هتضحي بالمليارات دي بسهوله
كده الايرادات دي بشكل اساسي جايه من ان
المنتج الاهم المتولد عن الكوبلت هو
بطاريات المركبات الكهربائيه منتج بدات
الاداره الامريكيه والشركات الامريكيه
الكبرى تنتبه لسيطره الصين عليه وتحاول لو
بصينا على وضع الصين والولايات المتحده
حاليا فيما يتعلق بصناعه البطاريات
الكهربائيه هنلاقي فرق شاسع جدا الصين
بتهيمن هيمنه كاسحه وبلا اي منافس في
الصناعه دي الصين يا اخوانا بتنتج حوالي
77% من الانتاج العالمي للبطاريات
الكهربائيه الولايات المتحده بقى بتنتج كم
حوالي 7% بس من البطاريات دي وده مش غريب
بالذات لما نعرف ان اكبر 10 شركات في
العالم لانتاج بطاريات السيارات في منهم
ست شركات صينيه على راسهم شركه سي اي تي
ال اللي بتنتج لوحدها اكتر من تلت
البطاريات في العالم علشان كده الامريكيين
صحيوا من النوم وبداوا يجروا علشان يلاقوا
موضع قدم لهم في المساحه الحساسه جدا دي
يعني من ناحيه الشركات هنلاقي ان الشركات
صناعه السيارات الامريكيه زي فورد جيرال
موتورز وتسلا اي نعم بيشتروا مكونات
بطاريات الكوبلت من الموردين اللي
بيعتمدوا على المناجم المملوكه للصين في
الكونغو لكن ده ما منعش شركه فورد مثلا من
انها تصرف حاليا مليارات الدولارات لبناء
مصانع بط خاصه بها جوه امريكا وبيجروا في
البحث والتطوير علشان يقللوا قدر الامكان
من حاجتهم للكوبلت نفسه من خلال تطوير
بدائل زي بطاريات معتمده على فوسفات حديد
الليثيوم او اعاده تدوير البطاريات
القديمه وعلى مستوى الاداره الامريكيه
هنلاقي اداره جو بايدن في اكتوبر 2022
اعلنت انها هتدي عقود بقراب التلاته مليار
دولار لحوالي 20 شركه في اكتر من عشر
ولايات علشان يوسعوا الانتاج المحلي من
بطاريات السيارات الكهربائيه وشبكات
الكهرباء وده جزء من حزمه الانفاق اللي
قدمتها اداره بايدن في اخر 2021 ولا
قيمتها 1.7 ترليون دولار وحاطط صرف على
البنيه التحتيه ومنها 174 مليار دولار
للفوز بسباق المركبات الكهربائيه فعلشان
كده لسه تحكم الصين في دوله حياه الكوبالت
من اول الاستخراج لحد المنتج النهائي مش
بيشكل ازمه ضخمه او خطيره للولايات
المتحده حاليا لكن ممكن يعمل الازمه دي لو
حصل شيء يحفز الصين لقطع امدادات الك زي
مثلا لو حصل توتر كبير متعلق بملف تايوان
او لوساد التقارب الصين الروسي او لو حصل
توتر كبير في بحر الصين الجنوبي الغني
بالثروات الطبيعيه وغيرها من ملفات
التنافس والتوتر الامريكيه الصينيه
فساعتها ده هيسبب ازمه للامريكيين لو ما
لحقوش نفسهم لكن غالبا الموضوع هياخد وقت
طويل جدا قبل ما تقدر اي قوه تنافس الصين
في المجال ده بما في ذلك امريكا لانك
ببساطه هتنافس في ايه ولا في ايه احنا
بنتكلم عن سلسله توريد طويله ومعقده
وعلشان تقدر تنافس فيها محتاج تكون حاضر
في كل مراحلها تقريبا ودي قصه محتاجه وقت
واستثمارات ضخمه جدا لحد هنا انا خلصت
كلامي وكالعاده عندي سؤال لحضراتكم هل في
دوله عربيه بتمتلك مورد طبيعي نادر بعيدا
عن النفط والغاز زي الكوبلت في الكونغو
كده ولو في ايه هو وتحبوا نعمل عنه حلقه
ولا لا هتابع ارائكم كلها في التعليقات ما
تنسوش تشوفوا رابط شركه تحت الفيديو للي
حابب يتداول وياخد بونص 100% لو فتح حساب
جديد وما تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه زي ما
اتفقنا ويا ريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا
لايك وشير للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكم
لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن نستفيدوا
سلام
[موسيقى]